qué tal como están es 13 de noviembre y
es momento de hablar de economía quien
france24 y por ello recibo con muchísimo
gusto daniel hablando con ramírez
daniela bienvenida renunció el
considerado cerebro británico del brics
y si hablan muy buenas noches se se
trata de dominique y cummings el asesor
más cercano al primer ministro boris
johnson
la imagen en que van a ver dejó a más de
uno sin palabras
cummings le saliendo de downing street
con caja de cartón en mano la forma en
la que abandonó la famosa casa 10 se
indicaría que no salió precisamente en
los mejores términos los medios
británicos hablan de desencuentros con
el gobierno y sus recientes cambios en
el gabinete
el asesor estrella del líder británico
era más que un simple consejero fue la
cabeza detrás del referendo que en 2016
dio el sí a la salida de reino unido de
la unión europea y su retiro se da justo
cuando el justo en medio de una
negociación comercial con bruselas que
está enquistada y a punto de fracasar
vaya imagen daniela con su caja
como bien nos identificas vamos a
nicaragua y es que ya probaron una
polémica ley de aguas si la
controvertida reforma la ley general de
aguas nacionales aprobada por el
parlamento de mayoría sandinista
centraliza el recurso en manos del
gobierno de daniel ortega lo que cambia
aquí es que a partir de ahora se permite
se permite entregar concesiones a
empresas privadas para ofrecer los
servicios de agua potable y saneamiento
básico en algunos lugares del país
aunque hoy los servicios están
controlados por el estado los
detractores de la medida se oponen a la
privatización de este recurso entre los
primeros en pronunciarse está el consejo
superior de la empresa privada este
gremio dice que las reformas no apuntan
a un beneficio alguno para los usuarios
del servicio sino que son parte del
modelo vertical y atropellador de un
estado que funciona según intereses
partidarios esto entre comillas la
empresa pública lleva años acumulando
millones de dólares en pérdidas
vamos con la cámara de diputados de
méxico y es que se aprobó finalmente el
presupuesto para el 2021 sí pues el
proyecto ha venido siendo discutido en
el transcurso de la semana pero la
última sesión duró más de medio día
finalmente el parlamento aprobó el
presupuesto federal para 2021 y lo
remitió al ejecutivo es decir al
presidente este paquete económico por 6
billones de pesos un poco más de 300 mil
millones de dólares supone una leve
reducción del gasto frente al año pasado
por eso es considerado el presupuesto
más austero del siglo 21 méxico está
pasando por una grave crisis económica
como toda la región lo hace este año las
autoridades esperan que el producto
interno bruto se contraiga en un 8%
pasamos al vecino del norte de mexico y
es que tick tock podrá operar por unos
días más en eeuu si pues los más de 100
millones de usuarios de la aplicación en
este país pueden estar tranquilos por
ahora y seguirla utilizando pero sólo
por 15 días el presidente de donald
trump emitió en agosto una orden para
que a más tardar el 12
es decir el jueves la empresa de origen
chino vendiera a sus operaciones en el
país de lo contrario no podría seguir
operando este viernes se otorgó una
prórroga de as hasta el 27 de noviembre
pero no porque así lo decidiera el
presidente sino que lo hizo para cumplir
una orden judicial emitida por el
tribunal de apelaciones del distrito de
columbia dentro de este plazo byte de
ans que soy su dueña podrá afinar los
detalles de un acuerdo con walt mart y
con oracle para lanzar una nueva
compañía y cumplir así con el mandato de
trompo es viernes
daniela cómo están los indicadores
económicos hubo máximo histórico en el
índice standard and poor's que es el
segundo más importante de la bolsa de
nueva york en medio de un optimismo
renovado por las vacunas anticopia en
europa las bolsas se recuperaron el
ánimo y mostraron alzas con la excepción
de londres el parque español cerró su
mejor semana en dos décadas y la segunda
mejor en toda su historia en américa
latina hubo alzas generalizadas en las
principales plazas bursátiles líder
en esta ocasión por brásil vamos con la
cifra el ya son los dos mil 832 millones
de dólares en pérdidas de ti state en el
año fiscal 2000 20 debido a la crisis
del cob y 19 de sus parques de
atracciones frente a los 10 mil millones
que había ganado en 2019
la empresa también anunció hoy que no
abrirá disneyland en california sólo
hasta 2021 correcto daniela pues muchas
gracias por este recorrido económico y
ustedes muchas gracias por su compañía
ya lo sabe vea más mucho más en france
[Música]